HERE WITH MORE OF THAT VIDEO.
JUST MOMENTS.
BUT FIRST, HILLARY 2.0.
OH, THAT'S THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE, PART ONE.
SOMETHING VERY ODD IS HAPPENING
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IT IS BEYOND THE USUAL JOCKEYING
FOR POLE POSITION BY THE
CANDIDATES DESPERATE TO REMAIN
VIABLE.
IT'S MORE THAN THAT.
THE FUNNY THING IS THE SUM OF SO
CALLED EXPERTS, EVEN OBAMA
REPORTEDLY, KEEP TELLING PEOPLE
THAT BIDEN SHOULDN'T BE THE
NOMINEE.
>> WE ARE NOW SITTING HERE WITH
THE DEMOCRATIC FRONT-RUNNER,
HAVING A SPOKESPERSON TRY AND
DEFEND HIS COMMENTS ON BUSING.
>> WHEN YOU ARE TRYING TO HIDE
THE CANDIDATE, THAT'S PROBABLY
MEANS YOU DON'T HAVE A GOOD
CANDIDATE.
THAT'S LIKE WEEKEND AT BERNIE'S,
WHERE THE GUY WAS DEAD, THEY HAD
TO PRETEND HE WAS ALIVE.
>> PRESIDENT OBAMA REPORTEDLY
TOLD JOE BIDEN DIRECTLY, QUOTE,
"YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO THIS, JOE,
YOU REALLY DON'T."
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
WHEN YOU LOVE TO BE IN THE ROOM
IN THAT CONVERSATION HAPPENED?
BUT DESPITE SOME SHAKY DEBATE
PERFORMANCES AND MORE THAN A FEW
MEDICAL ALERT MOMENTS, BIDEN HAS
GAINED SEVEN POINTS ON HIS
RIVALS SINCE JUNE.
YOU CAN CALL THIS MEDICARE
ADVANTAGE.
HE NOW HAS A DOUBLE-DIGIT LEAD
OVER HIS 2020 RIVALS.
BUT THERE ARE REASONS FOR
CONCERN.
THE CLOSER YOU LOOK AT BIDEN,
THE MORE IT ALL COMES INTO FOCU
FOCUS.
DOESN'T THIS BEGIN TO FEEL LIKE
THE HILLARY CAMPAIGN?
THE FRAILTY, THE FLIP-FLOP, THE
CONFLICTS ABROAD, AND OF COURSE,
THE MESSY FAMILY LIFE.
BIDEN'S CAMPAIGN IS LOOKING LIKE
A BAD SEQUEL.
HILLARY 2.0.
IN THE WARNING SIGNS ARE ALL
THERE.
JUST LOOK AT BOTH OF THE
CANDIDATES, THE OVERALL FITNESS
FOR OFFICE.
HILLARY'S CAMPAIGN SPENT A LOT
OF TIME FIGHTING OFF CONCERNS
ABOUT THE FORMER FIRST LADY'S
HEALTH.
FOR HER, IT WAS QUESTIONS
SURROUNDING HER PHYSICAL
CONDITION.
>> NEW QUESTIONS THIS MORNING
SURROUNDING HILLARY CLINTON'S
HEALTH.
SPEAK OF THE DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE
NOW FORCED TO CANCEL CAMPAIGN
EVENTS IN CALIFORNIA AFTER SHE
COLLAPSED AT THE 9/11 MEMORIAL.
>> Laura: BOY, THEY SHOVED HER
INTO THAT VAN FAST, DIDN'T
THEY?
AFTER THE FALL, HILLARY'S
DOCTORS SCRAMBLED TO REASSURE
VOTERS BUT MY OVERALL IMPRESSION
IS THAT MRS. CLINTON REMAINS
HEALTHY AND CONTINUES TO REMAIN
HEALTHY AND FIT TO SERVE AS
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
WELL, AT 76, BIDEN IS EVEN OLDER
THAN THE FORMER FIRST LADY.
BUT FOR HIM COME OF THE CONCERNS
ARE ABOUT HIS MENTAL OR
COGNITIVE FITNESS.
"POLITICO" HAVE BIG JOURNALIST
EQUIVALENT OF A MEDIC MEDEVAC --
FINDING THE SURGEON WHO OPERATED
ON BIDEN IN 1998, CLAIMING
"BIDEN IS EVERY BIT AS SHARP AS
HE WAS 31 YEARS AGO, I
HAVEN'T SEEN ANY CHANGE.
WHICH LED MANY TO WONDER, YOU
MEAN, BIDEN HAS BEEN LIKE THIS
FOR DECADES?
>> THE COUNTRY WASN'T BILLED BY
WALL STREET BANKERS, CEOs, AND
HEDGE FUND MANAGERS.
UNION WORKERS, AND THEIR FUTURES
AND THEIR PENSIONS.
INVESTING MUCH MORE IN MEDICAL
RESEARCH TO CONQUER DEVASTATING
DISEASES LIKE CANCER, ADDICTION.
>> Laura: BUT DON'T WORRY,
REMEMBER, THE SURGEON SAID HE IS
AS SHARP AS HE WAS 31 YEARS AGO.
WELL, BIDEN, LIKE HILLARY, IS
WILLING TO JETTISON LONG-HELD
POLITICAL POSITIONS TO WIN OVER
THE RADICAL PART OF HIS PARTY
APPEARED ON TRADE, FOR EXAMPLE,
HILLARY SUPPORTED THE
TRANS-PACIFIC PARTNERSHIP, THE
TPP, WHILE IN OBAMA'S CABINET.
>> I DID SAY, WHEN I WAS
SECRETARY OF STATE THREE YEARS
AGO THAT IT WOULD BE THE GOLD
STANDARD.
IT WAS JUST FINALLY NEGOTIATED
LAST WEEK.
AND, IN LOOKING AT IT, IT DIDN'T
MEET MY STANDARDS, MY STANDARDS
FOR MORE NEW GOOD JOBS FOR
AMERICANS, FOR RAISING WAGES FOR
AMERICANS.
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I
CAN LOOK INTO THE EYES OF ANY
MIDDLE-CLASS AMERICAN MEN SAY
"THIS WILL HELP RAISE YOUR
WAGES, AND I CONCLUDED I COULD
NOT.
>> Laura: MR. FLIP, MEET
MRS. FLOP.
SAME STORY, OF COURSE, BUT
NAFTA, BY THE WAY, WAS SIGNED BY
HER HUSBAND.
>> I THINK EVERYONE IS IN FAVOR
OF FREE AND FAIR TRADE, AND I
THINK THAT NAFTA IS PROVING ITS
WORTH.
I SAID I WOULD LIKE TO
RENEGOTIATE IT WHEN I RAN BACK
INTO THOUSAND EIGHT.
>> Laura: NO, NO.
AND AS FOR BIDEN, BACK IN THE
OLDEN DAYS OF 2015, HIS OFFICE
THAT HE "SUPPORTS THE TPP
AGREEMENT AND WILL HELP PASS IT
ON THE HILL."
BUT HERE IS BIDEN LAST MONTH.
>> I WOULD NOT REJOIN THE TPP AS
IT WAS INITIALLY PUT FORWARD.
I WOULD INSIST THAT WE
RENEGOTIATE PIECES OF FAT.
>> Laura: DID HE SAY TPP?
WE FORGOT THAT IN OUR GAFFE
MONTAGE.
YOU SEE HIS ANCIENT POSITION OF
FOUR YEARS AGO WAS THE
ESTABLISHMENT DEMOCRAT POSITION.
PRO-FREE TRADE AND
PRO-GLOBALIZATION, NO QUESTIONS
ASKED.
BUT THAT IS NOT WITH THE ENERGY
OF HIS PARTY IS TODAY.
BIDEN, LIKE HILLARY, IS TRYING
TO PLACATE THE SOCIALISTS IN THE
RANKS OF THE PARTY, BLUNTING THE
CANDIDACY OF WARREN AND SANDERS.
THAT IS WHY THEY DO THAT.
AND THEN THERE ARE THE MESSY
FAMILY MATTERS.
HILLARY HAD BILL'S SEEDY
REPUTATION IN THE ANVIL OF THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION AROUND HER
NECK, A PERSONAL FUND FOR THOSE
WHO WANTED ACCESS TO THE NEXT
PRESIDENT.
AS FOR JOE BIDEN, HE HAS HIS
SON, HUNTER, LUCRATIVE BUSINESS
DEALS IN THE UKRAINE, AND
HUNTERS CHINESE BUSINESS DEALS